das ist schon eine kleine Sensation
Mario Bart hat einen Auftritt in
blutsbrüders in diesem kleinen special
versuche ich rauszubekommen wer außerdem
noch in dem Kinofilm erscheint und gibt
es einen Jahresrückblick 2011 von Sido
2010 der war ja sensationell und Sido
klärt uns auf ob wir darauf gespannt
sein können oder wenn nein auf was also
bis dann bleib
dran eine Frage brennt unter den
Fingernägeln weil ich habe ein Cameo
Auftritt entdeckt im Film und daraufhin
habe ich mir danach gedacht da muss es
doch sicher mehr geben Mario Bart taucht
auf irgendwo also nicht verraten nein
verrate ich nicht das müssen die Leute
selber rauskriegen wo Mario Bart in dem
Film auftaucht sehr lustig das ist dir
aufgefallen es gibt noch einen ja einen
versteckten ist DIN ja Durin auch die
ist auch auch drin ist auch drin ja kurz
Co aber das merkt man schon so ja und
dann noch jemand also drei es gibt drei
wer den noch ne verraten nicht verr
nicht an welcher Stelle denn na guck
doch noch mal kennt man den ja ja jaer
sie kennt
man komm klein deswegen es ist schon es
ist schon eigentlich ist zu viel dass du
Mario Bart gesagt hast weil jetzt wird
jeder natürlich dan gucken und dann
findet man ihn auch ja denke ich mal ja
aber mus aber es gibt ich habe Leute
gesprochen hab gesagt was nee habe ich
nicht gesehen aber er ist drin ja er ist
drin er sprichtar ja ja der spricht
sogar ja ja das ist Wahnsinn okay aber
es gibt andere Filme Muppets kommt im
Januar raus da sind die ganzen Kamo
Auftritte da sind ohne Ende welche drin
sind alle aufgelistet aber ihr wollt das
mehr so unter der Decke halten ja na ja
weil bei uns ist Cameo ja nicht so Cameo
sondern eher so für die für die Fans
wenn die den Film öfter sehen was noch
zum finden was man so finden kann da
gibt's viel ich sag dir da gibt's nicht
nur diese C Auftritte sondern auch so da
gibt's viel noch zu entdecken besonders
auf der Kinoleinwand für ich muss ganz
sag ich habe den Film im Vorfeld
bestimmt drei vier Mal gesehen aber im
Kino habe ich noch mal Sachen gesehen wo
ich dachte diese Riesen Leinwand ja die
lässt dich mehr sehen als so ein
laptopmitor also auf die Requisiten
achten die Wohnung nehm ich mal an genau
angucken ich würde mir alles mal genau
angucken kein kleiner Hinweis wie gesagt
wir haben uns wir haben den Film
wirklich mit sehr viel Liebe und Geduld
und gestaltungs so Zeug gemacht ja wir
haben uns da wirklich sehr sehr viel
Mühe gegeben auch im Vorfeld mit
schreiben und so weiter und diese ganzen
kleinen Sachen haben wir uns haben wir
mit Absicht gemacht und deswegen würden
wir die jetzt nicht verraten ja darauf
kommt's ja an im Film okay gut also
viele Überraschung also mit viel Liebe
wieer Jahresrückblick 2010 wie der z.B
genau gut okay gibt aber es gibt kein
Jahresrückblick 2011 ich wurde schon
gefragt aber dafür genau ein Jahr später
den Jahresrückblick habe ich ja glaube
ich am
29.12 2010 released jetzt kommt am
29.122 kommt dann der Film ja also ach
okay das ist quasi dein Jahresrückblick
sozusagen was heißt mein Jahresrückblick
oh ja dam damit ihr seh was ich so das
ganze Jahr über mit was ich so zu tun
hatte super
prima